[Música]
el mundo entero fue testigo de las
imágenes del allanamiento de Mara lago
la residencia campestre del ex
presidente Donald Trump en el estado de
Florida en el sur de Estados Unidos los
titulares en los medios de comunicación
no se hicieron esperar y por supuesto
las preguntas tampoco Por qué están
investigando al expresidente Lo cierto
es que son varias Las investigaciones
que buscan indagar sobre algunos
comportamientos del ex mandatario
durante su paso por la Casa Blanca en
Washington y también de su etapa como
Hombre de negocios muchos años antes de
entrar a la escena política de Estados
Unidos veamos algunos datos
Comencemos Entonces por algunas de las
investigaciones la primera de ellas los
archivos nacionales el FBI y también las
autoridades estadounidenses intentan
determinar si Donald Trump se llevó
algunos documentos clasificados de la
casa blanca y los depositó en su
residencia en el sur de la Florida Trump
calificó esta investigación y este
allanamiento como un de autoridad el
departamento de Justicia Investiga
también un posible caso de mal manejo de
información confidencial otras
investigaciones en curso están
relacionadas al asalto a la sede del
Capitolio en Washington ocurrida el 6 de
enero del 2021 y sobre los intentos o
presuntos intentos del expresidente de
revertir los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales de hecho hay
una investigación paralela una por parte
del departamento de justicia y otra por
parte de una comisión del Congreso sobre
la insurrección del 6 de enero Trump
enfrenta también múltiples demandas
civiles Hay también una declaración de
un juez Federal que negó la petición de
Donald Trump de rechazar las demandas no
civiles sino las que fueron presentadas
por legisladores y por guardias del
Capitolio en cuanto al caso del estado
de Georgia el ex presidente Trump es
investigado por Aparentemente haber
llamado al secretario de estado el
estado de Georgia Brad Rafael para
presionarlo para que abro comillas
encontrará los votos necesarios para
revertir la derrota de Trump en el
estado de Georgia algo que también está
bajo investigación entre tanto en el
estado de Nueva York hay una
investigación civil en contra de Trump
sobre una década de irregularidades
financieras de la Trump organization
para acceder a diferentes créditos
bancarios
el ex presidente Trump ha dicho que todo
esto hace parte de una casa de brujas
Qué tan cierto puede ser hay intereses
políticos oscuros que buscan que Trump
no pueda aspirar a la presidencia
nuevamente en el 2024 pero al negarse a
testificar y dar información Trump está
escondiendo algo Hay riesgo de que el ex
presidente Donald Trump vaya prisión que
eso es lo que se pregunta la mayoría de
las personas pues lo vamos a analizar
entonces en el debate de France 24 y
para conversar y profundizar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a María Herrera ella
es doctora en ciencias jurídicas y
presidente de la asamblea hispana del
partido republicano en la ciudad de
Miami en el sur del Estado de la Florida
y en la ciudad de West Palm Beach se
encuentra Daniel lustick él es abogado
especialista en áreas constitucionales y
Ley Federal de los Estados Unidos les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar todas
sus preguntas y sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
en Instagram y Facebook en donde no se
encuentran como arroba france24_es y
arrobas antilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta numeral el debate
f24 también en YouTube pueden Seguir
nuestra señal en streaming y También
saluda a las personas que nos están
escuchando a través de nuestro podcast
Los invito para que escuchen todos los
contenidos del debate de France 24 en
diferentes plataformas estamos en Apple
podcast en Spotify deezer y TuneIn
le doy la bienvenida entonces a María
Herrera en la ciudad de Miami María como
siempre Un gusto saludarla Gracias por
estar con nosotros Punto de partida y
para este Punto de partida pregunta para
conocer diferentes posiciones de cara al
debate retomo las palabras del
expresidente Donald Trump esto sería
entonces una cacería de brujas para
evitar que trompas pide nuevamente a la
presidencia que piensa usted bienvenida
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación
Bueno ahí están las señales no
evidentemente se produce en un momento
muy particular no donde el partir
demócrata Está peor que nunca donde este
país está viviendo la peor crisis
inflacionaria de los últimos 40 años la
crisis migratoria completamente
descontrolada política exterior
vergonzosa Entonces el partido demócrata
se enfrenta a unas elecciones de
noviembre 2022 en la que se están dando
cuenta que las elecciones primarias
inclusive todos los candidatos que ha
apoyado Donald Trump han ganado y que
los índices de
bajísimo de apoyo al presidente biden
Pues la verdad que deja mucho que desear
y le dan una amplia mayoría al supuesto
candidato favorito Donald Trump la
semana pasada hace dos semanas cuando se
produjo la Cumbre de América First en
bici y muchos otros medios ya anunciaban
que iba a haber una nueva investigación
en el marco del comité de la comisión
del 6 de enero
muchos sospecha y sobre todo también
cuando vemos el trato tan
discriminatorio y la cantidad de dudas
que nos surgen cuando hay evidencia
Clara de posibles delitos por ejemplo
del hijo del presidente yo bailén Hunter
biden de felonías de delitos federales
graves o lo que pasó con el caso de
hillary Clinton o cómo se ha politizado
el FBI y el departamento de justicia en
la que se ha permitido inclusive crear
una falsa absolutamente falsa teoría de
colusión entre Rusia y Donald Trump por
eso no creemos que esto se cree que se
trata de un caso que tenga ningún futuro
en este basado en la justicia le doy la
palabra ahora a Daniel lustick en West
Palm Beach también allí en el estado de
la Florida Punto de partida cree usted
que esto es una cacería de brujas tal
como lo dijo el ex presidente Trump para
evitar que aspire a un nuevo mandato
presidencial
en realidad en la realidad no no lo creo
porque
el departamento de justicia y los jueces
de las Cortes federales son personas que
llevan su trabajo desde una manera
seria y tratan de hacer de manera
igual para todo el mundo y y realidad
escuchar el el que se habla acerca de
del hijo del presidente de de de de
hillary de todas esas otras cosas es
como un desvío a lo que a lo que está
sucediendo y lo que estás haciendo ahora
ese al final de cuentas
se están haciendo investigaciones
entonces vale siempre son secretas en
Estados Unidos hasta que exista alguna
clase C de información específica que se
tiene que traerá luz luz investigaciones
esas empresas llevan por secreto para
poder proteger a la persona que está
investigada el material que se
investigado Entonces entonces el pensar
en un momento El tratar de decir que
esto Esto es una una cacería de brujas
lo que haces es crear esa hace de de
diálogo que nosotros vemos en muchos de
otros países en los que la persona que
estaba en poder empieza a a tratar de de
quedar el diálogo porque sabe algo más
más
para poder minimizar lo que va a pasar
Daniel tenemos tenemos un problema
técnico con su audio tenemos un un
retorno le pido a mis compañeros del
área técnica que revisen ese audio y me
informen Tan pronto retomemos la
conexión de la mejor manera con Daniel
para tener un audio en óptimas
condiciones Mientras tanto mientras
solucionamos este problema Yo sigo
conversando con María en la ciudad de
Miami ya abriendo un poco el debate
analizando diferentes puntos que tenemos
sobre este tema
yo hablaba y mencionaba al inicio en la
introducción María los múltiples frentes
de investigación que está haciendo
cara el expresidente Trump hablando de
garantías que tantas garantías tiene el
ex presidente Trump para enfrentarse a
estos múltiples casos que y estas
múltiples investigaciones que hay en su
contra
se puede confiar en estos procesos el ex
presidente está tranquilo con los
procedimientos pese a las declaraciones
que ha dado a los medios a través de sus
redes sociales
no yo creo que el expresidente Donald
Trump no puede estar tranquilo porque
esto es una persecución por mucho
frentes hemos visto lo que pasaba esta
semana en Nueva York Púas has explicado
muy bien la cantidad de juicio que hay
contra el ex mandatario precisamente
porque es un hombre que no le gusta a la
izquierda estadounidense recordemos que
en Estados Unidos la izquierda controla
y domina también no solo los medios de
comunicación que pueden tergiversar
Digamos como un potencial Jurado
tu casa al ex mandatario pero también
los fiscales los fiscales generales
hablamos de América
una persona que iba a llegar al tribunal
supremo que se propuso por parte de
Barack Obama señor el que ha aprobado y
lo ha tenido que reconocer hace
escasamente una hora que él sí aprobó la
orden de allanamiento que les mandatario
cuando la digamos la vocera la portavoz
de la Casa Blanca dijo que no tenían
ningún conocimiento de que iban a entrar
en la residencia de de Donald tru Por
otra parte la fiscal Leticia James en
Nueva York una mujer abiertamente
demócrata que que está viendo estas
causas contra el ex mandatario y que
prometió bertamente ir en contra de de
Donald Trump Hay muchísimo frente La
garantías desde luego las garantías
constitucionales son las que tenemos
todos pero hay un objetivo Claro que
Donald Trump no se presente como
candidato a las próximas elecciones de
20-24 porque lo que demuestran las
encuestas lo que está demostrando todos
los candidatos que el digamos el team
tan político de América First de Estados
Unidos primero en dorsa y apoyo y en sí
mismo el Donald Trump están ganando y
están Arrasando Y eso es lo que va a
pasar noviembre 2022 y noviembre 2024
hemos retomado la conexión con Daniel
luz y creo que ya solucionamos este
problema con ese retorno que teníamos
Daniel otra vez Le repito la pregunta
entonces para que ya se incorpore con
nosotros al al debate de la discusión y
este análisis le está preguntando a
María por las garantías que tiene el ex
presidente Trump para estos múltiples
frentes de investigación que tiene
múltiples
momentos o escenarios en los que va a
tener que enfrentar a la justicia dar
explicaciones o bueno dar cuenta de lo
que sucedió durante su durante su
mandato qué piensa usted
las garantías de la Constitución son
garantías que van a cada persona
sin importar Quién es una persona tiene
derecho a no incriminarse en una clase
de procedimiento civil o criminal cuando
existe un potencial de una persecución
criminal o un cargo criminal la persona
tiene el del derecho de no testificar y
no probar no no dar información
que pueda ser usada en su contra en un
ámbito criminal y eso fue lo que el
señor Trump hizo en Nueva York cuando le
iban a hacer la declaración jurada
tomó su derecho constitucional y
evitó contestar preguntas
en su deposición acerca de este caso
civil que tienen en contra de la
Organización de él en Nueva York
Esa esa tomar esa posición no quiere
decir de que por ejemplo en un caso
civil no se vaya a utilizar Esa esa
decisión que él tomó en contra de él en
término de lo que puede pensar el Jurado
si llega a llegar el caso a un Jurado
acerca del
de algún fraude civil que pueda existir
pero también también demuestra que
existe cierta clase de preocupación de
que cualquier cosa que él pueda decir
bajo juramento pueda llegar a ser algo
que que pueda ser utilizado en contra
del en cualquier procedimiento especial
después Daniel creo que es oportuno para
el contexto de la audiencia América
Latina ya le doy la palabra a María en
la ciudad de Miami creo que es
importante explicar acá ese ese apartado
de la quinta enmienda que es a lo que él
se acogió cuando se presentó ante la
justicia en ante la Fi en la ciudad de
Nueva York en los últimos días en qué
consiste esta enmienda que es
puntualmente para los que no conocemos a
profundidad la legislación de Estados
Unidos
él la quinta enmienda le da el derecho a
una persona que que se niegue en dar
testimonio que se puede utilizar en
contra de sí mismo en
enfrente de la policía o en cualquier
procedimiento civil o penal si existe la
oportunidad de que haya una clase de una
clase de persecución
penal después entonces esa es una
enmienda constitucional que existe desde
el principio de la república
importantes aclaración hacer Claridad
sobre ese punto para entender el
contexto de lo que estamos viendo en
Estados Unidos María regreso con usted
para hablar sobre los escenarios
posibles que pueden venir en un futuro
cercano muchos especulan sobre lo que
significa esta coyuntura para el ex
presidente Trump un momento oportuno
para lanzar esa esperada candidatura
para el 2024 que muchos sectores están
esperando que así sea otros dicen que no
que esto lleva a que la candidatura
espere unos días O tal vez espere hasta
después de las elecciones de medio
término debido a que esta coyuntura
afecta un poco la imagen del ex
presidente de Cara a las elecciones del
medio término para los republicanos y
para su candidatura qué análisis hace
usted desde la perspectiva republicana
Bueno yo creo que él debería anunciar
que va a presentarse como candidato a
las presidenciales inmediatamente
después de lo que estamos viendo después
de ver lo que vimos por ejemplo de cómo
se le trató a hillary Clinton no con
James que él mismo anunció que a pesar
de que se había violado la ley Pues no
iba a tener repercusión penal y el trato
diferenciador con el ex mandatario y lo
que vemos Hunter byden montándose en el
avión presidencial después de verlo
consumiendo cocaína con prostitutas lo
que vemos del tema del tráfico de
menores Yo creo que es el momento
perfecto porque los estadounidenses
están con Deseando que alguien retoma el
control de este país estamos viviendo
unos niveles nefastos de crecimiento
económico con una frontera que hoy el
departamento de Ministerio de seguridad
nacional ha anunciado que va a levantar
el protocolo de protección inmigrantes
estamos recibiendo más de 240.000
inmigrantes todos los meses la cifra
mayor desde que surgió seguridad
nacional una crisis política exterior yo
creo que alguien tiene que lanzar la
candidatura cuanto antes y yo creo que
están Tienen respaldo de la mayoría de
los republicanos y de muchos demócratas
que se dan cuenta que estamos cruzando
las líneas peligrosísimas porque como
decía el senador marco Rubio esto
solamente se ve en países y repúblicas
bananeras el uso la politización de las
agencias federales de inteligencia del
departamento de Justicia para ir detrás
de tus opositores políticos porque no
han sido capaz de acabar con él ni en
los juicios políticos ni en los
tribunales de Justicia es un momento
ideal para Donald Trump María en ese
escenario si él anuncia esta candidatura
en estos días antes de esas elecciones
de medio término que están previstas
para noviembre no corren el riesgo de
que estas elecciones se conviertan en
una especie de referendo como de aval de
esa candidatura de para los círculos
republicanos y para los círculos de
apoyo que pueda tener Trump qué análisis
puede hacer usted
absolutamente y van a arrasar todos los
candidatos que están dorzando Donald
Trump vemos el caso de Kansas Arizona
Wisconsin Michigan todos los candidatos
que han defendido la integridad
electoral que han defendido el programa
América First basado en la seguridad
nacional por encima de todo la
prosperidad en todos los sectores y en
todas las comunidades independientemente
de la raza del origen de la opinión
política o religiosa están siendo los
candidatos que están ganando a nivel de
gobernación a nivel de senado y Congreso
Estatal y a nivel Federal Si vemos los
resultados de las últimas semanas el
partido demócrata no tenía otra que
intentar detener al ex mandatario y
todos aquellos candidatos que van a
arrasar en noviembre 2022 sí Daniel
regresó con usted este escenario es
bastante particular lo que estamos
viendo en Estados Unidos nunca habíamos
visto o por lo menos en la historia
reciente un allanamiento la casa de un
ex presidente ni este
múltiples escenarios de
hay escenarios similares hay precedentes
en la historia de Estados Unidos de un
ex presidente investigado a este nivel o
de alguna figura política destacada de
Estados Unidos que haya tenido que
enfrentar un escenario similar que usted
pueda recordar
un escenario similar no no puedo
recordarlo pero lo que le puedo decir a
a la audiencia en Latinoamérica es que
cuando una persona toma documentos que
son clasificados y confidenciales no lo
regresa no dice lo que tomó nos dice la
verdad lo que tomó entonces
existen leyes en este país que dicen que
que esas cosas no se deben hacer y una
de las penalidades son que esta persona
no pueda volver a tomar
oficina pública si es que llega a ser si
es que existe una convicción Entonces
yo creo que lo importante aquí es
escuchamos mucho lo que le dicen en
Estados Unidos Eh
muchas cosas que que se dicen que se
dicen que se dicen pero en realidad
Cuáles son los hechos existe
investigación bueno dos investigaciones
directamente que tienen que ver con la
presidencia de la primera el tomar
documentos clasificados y documentos que
eran parte del archivo nacional no
devolverlos
ciertos documentos Fueron retrevidos por
medio de una en junio de este año y
luego hubo una información acerca de más
documentos mientras que la propiedad
donde vive el señor Trump se utiliza
para para que gente de muchos países
de ahora voy a solita de otros lugares
vengan ahí existe la posibilidad de que
esa información esté en riesgo al no ser
presidente de él él no tiene derecho de
tener posesión de la información
entonces
se ha visto algo así no no se ha visto
algo así el departamento de Justicia
el empezar a a comentar acerca de de que
el departamento de Justicia es de un
lado o es del otro lado de la Esfera
política no no es justo porque sería de
un lado Sería bien si si van en contra
de por ejemplo huntervident pero no está
bien si investigan al Señor Trump
entonces tiene que ser algo neutral
tiene que ser algo
que se investiga todo mundo sin importar
de Quién es la persona claro y eso lo
que está pasando al final de cuenta
cuando salga el el formulario de
allanamiento ahí es donde uno va a ver
qué es exactamente los cargos que
existen que se piensa que existen
encontrarse el señor Trump y así se
puede en realidad a ver qué es lo que lo
que lo que es porque aunque eso se le
presentó el nódulo que hizo no quiso
ofrecer información al respecto Daniel
antes de pasar a hablar porque usted
toca un punto importante es la
independencia de poderes allí en Estados
Unidos que está haciendo muy criticada
en este momento y sé que lo vamos a
poder debatir a profundidad con María
quería preguntarle a qué se está
exponiendo el expresidente en términos
legales al ser acusado a al ir a un
proceso
y recibir algún tipo de Sentencia o
algún tipo de de castigo por parte de la
justicia de Estados Unidos a qué se está
exponiendo el ex presidente
Bueno una de las cosas mínimas puede ser
de que no pueda tener oficina pública
otra vez
existe la posibilidad de que el el si se
encontraría si se hace un un un un cargo
formal y lo cual lo cual hay algo que es
importante saber y entender el
departamento de justicia y y las fuentes
de ejercicio de forzamiento de la
policía el espía hay ellos no no van a
ir a un lugar sin tener suficiente
evidencia para ir al lugar a y hacer un
allanamiento aquí esto no funciona como
quizás en otros lugares otros países
Aquí van con con ya el 90% de la tarea
ya está realizada entonces
y y el castigo puede ser puede puede ser
prisión si es que se encuentra culpable
puede ser probatoria todo depende
pero hay algo importante también que yo
quiero comentar y es la el el
esta esta allanamiento no hubo poder no
se hubo poder realizar si no se había
firmado por un juez yo he practicado
enfrente del juez que que firmó este
allanamiento este juez no entra una
orden sino esta completamente
con con los puntos sobre la ies con las
la rayas sobre la t y completamente
analizada bien este este no es un señor
que nada más pone estampillas en los
documentos sino que él quiere saber cuál
es la ley
a que se está refiriendo y cuál es y Y
cómo van las cosas y y el tratamiento
que ha recibido es completamente no
justificado
importante esa aclaración Daniel en paso
a preguntarle a María estaba mencionando
el tema de la libertad y la
independencia de poderes en Estados
Unidos muy criticada en los últimos días
a raíz de estos hechos recientes allí en
la Unión Americana su punto de vista
María su perspectiva sobre esta
independencia
Bueno sobre la independencia sobre lo
que ha dicho mi colega para empezar Por
supuesto que la independencia del poder
judicial está en el predicho de hecho
hasta el Washington post ha tenido que
borrar y lo ha hecho 10 besos ayer un
Twitter diciendo
el departamento de justicia y después
aprobó la orden de allanamiento Por otra
parte recordarle que el juez que ha
firmado esa orden también se le ha
criticado mucho y se le ha investigado
por sus posibles vínculos no como un
donante de Obama y también con sus
vínculos al Jeffrey Einstein Es verdad
que también se donó para el partido
republicano y estoy completamente de en
desacuerdo con lo que ha dicho mi colega
de que la de que el digamos de que la
justicia en Estados Unidos está haciendo
o debería queremos que sea totalmente
Imparcial Por supuesto que sí pero qué
hacemos con el caso de hunterviday que
cuando tú hablas por ejemplo en el tema
de que se entró en la morada de Donald
Trump porque se Mistral porque se
sacaron documentos del departamento de
la Casa Blanca qué hacemos con los
30.000 emails que borró y que trató de
forma completamente nefasta la ex
secretaria de estado hillary Clinton nos
vemos el mismo trato y para terminar lo
que estamos viviendo aquí en Estados
Unidos desde que revocaron la sentencias
de Rober versus bueyes 50 ataques a
clínicas prohibidas el FBI tiene
información y no hace nada no hay ningún
solo arresto y después el foco solamente
es el Donald Trump y su familia Yo creo
que esto sí tiene tintes políticos y lo
tiene porque nos encontramos en un
momento en el que en Estados Unidos se
define el futuro político de este país
si no fuera así no estaríamos viendo
artículo tras artículos de los medios de
comunicación y borrar tweets y Buscar la
forma de dañar la imagen del
expresidente que de por sí lo han hecho
todo para acabar con la imagen dejen que
la democracia sigue adelante yo estoy
Completamente de acuerdo que si la orden
ha sido firmada por un juez
independiente estupendo que que entren
Pero se tiene que conocer como él si
decía el formulario de allanamiento las
causas y lo que queremos ver es lo que
pasa con huntervival En qué pasó Por qué
no se investigó Y por qué no se acabó de
penalizar el tratamiento de los email
por hillary Clinton y qué va a pasar
aquí pues yo creo que absolutamente nada
porque solamente es un juego político
Daniel su opinión al respecto este
desequilibrio de acuerdo al punto de
vista de María en la aplicación de la
ley sobre todo en ese caso de la
entonces ex secretaria de estado hillary
Clinton un tema que le dio la vuelta al
mundo esa eliminación de Esos teléfonos
móviles y esos correos electrónicos su
opinión
esto esto lo que se llama tratar de de
moverse a un lado no eso que lo que lo
que nosotros vemos en en cuando una
persona trata de deflectar la situación
empieza a hablar de otras cosas y en
este momento lo que está sucediendo no
es no es lo que pasó con con hillary
Clinton sino que lo que está pasando en
este momento con la investigación que
está pendiente al al expresidente y lo
que a mí me parece
más me da más pena Es que empiecen a
hablar acerca de un juez de que que le
donó a a Obama que esto con otro la
mayor todos los jueces que puso el señor
Trump en en la corte de distrito en las
diferentes cortes federales que tuvieron
en presencia los casos de las elecciones
todos
dijeron que no había fraude electoral
los jueces que entran a ser jueces en
las Cortes federales son personas que
que hacen juicio por parte de la ley de
la regla de la Constitución no De quién
son políticos de que el el el el hacer
un ataque sin fundamento Así es es Es
pavoroso para el sistema judicial y crea
el problema que ahora hay una persona
que es una un un juez extraordinario que
tiene que estar protegido por los los
Marshalls porque porque hay un montón de
personas que que que se creen la la esta
esta esta clase de de de de historia
el el el el la referencia epsting ya
hemos visto varias fotos de Donald Trump
como el señor efting en en
en el avión Así que no tiene sentido
todas estas todas estas referencias son
para tratar de deflectar lo que está
sucediendo en este momento y lo que está
sucediendo es que haya una actitud es
una una investigación activa el empezar
a hablar de de clínica de aborto y decir
de la espía que no está haciendo nada No
tampoco tiene sentido por dos razones
una el el lo que hizo este caso que que
quitó a robby wait que es el caso que
decía que la una mujer podía abortar en
Estados Unidos es que le devolvió a los
Estados el derecho de El derecho de de
de de de forzar sus leyes acerca del
aborto
Entonces no va a haber una una envoltura
Federal en este Sentido y la otra cosa
es que ni ella ni yo sabemos lo que está
pasando con el FBI y con las
investigaciones que tienen activas
porque estas son secretas claro
importante también Esa esa aclaración en
María haga una pregunta que yo ya viendo
su punto de vista puedo intuir Cuál va a
ser su respuesta pero
se la hago porque viene de parte de
alguno de nuestros televidentes a través
de internet y es qué tanto esta
candidatura o esta posible candidatura
de Trump es netamente porque de verdad
quiere construir y terminar ese proyecto
político que él tiene en mente para
Estados Unidos O que tanto tiene esto de
un componente de salvavidas la única
forma de él salvarse estas
investigaciones y lo que viene aquí en
adelante es poder llegar a la casa
blanca y no ser investigado Cuál es su
respuesta
Bueno yo creo que la verdad que la
gestión del ex mandatario Donald Trump
fue Fabulosa vimos los índices más bajos
de desempleo entre las minorías las
mujeres los hispanos yo creo que Estados
Unidos con país seguro donde la frontera
segura no estaban en la frontera Sur no
estaba en llamas como lo está Hoy no nos
metió en una guerra y tiene el apoyo
tiene el apoyo de su base tiene el apoyo
de muchísimas personas que quieren que
el mandatario venga y regrese a la casa
blanca él mismo ha dicho que si él
anunciase que no se iba a postular como
candidato el 2024 dejaría dejarían de
permitirlo yo a mi colega le digo Oiga
es que los datos están ahí evidentemente
que sí que un juez puede ser y queremos
creer en el departamento de justicia y
creemos querer en todos los jueces pero
los datos están aquí a quien ha
representado él a quien ha representado
la fiscal y no exponer en tela de juicio
simplemente el sistema de Justicia sino
que también esos datos que el público
general tiene conocer entonces no es
tampoco mandar la pelota a otro lado
simplemente conocer quién está detrás de
todo esto y cuando la Casa Blanca dice
que no lo conocía pues simplemente no
nos lo creemos
Daniel analizando de nuevo las
elecciones de medio término y partiendo
teniendo como punto de partida todas
estas especulación y toda esta
conspiración que pueda haber
supuestamente que son las fuerzas
demócratas gestando todas estas
investigaciones viéndolo desde ese punto
de vista sin decir acá que eso es cierto
porque no tenemos prueba de ellos
simplemente partiendo de esa de esa
especulación qué tanto le puede jugar
esto en contra a los demócratas en esas
elecciones de medio término que todo
esto que supuestamente están gestando
Según dicen desde los sectores
republicanos les juegue en contra
dos cosas la primera
los jueces me interesa tocar esto porque
yo yo este es mi campo laboral Y
obviamente yo practico enfrente de
jueces federales y específicamente
practicado mucho en frente de este juez
los jueces tienen turnos y cuando se
presentan las las las las fórmulas de
allanamiento si se le presenta el jueves
de turno Ese es el jueves que la va a
firmar no es un juez distinto sino que
va a ser el juez que está de turno en
este sentido le tocó a este juez que
estaba de turno
en en término de de los métodos
las elecciones del término medio todo
depende de lo que diga el el inventario
que van a que va a salir a la luz y el
el el formulario de allanamiento porque
porque aparte de eso también está la
investigación del comi del 6 de junio
que nadie de 6 de enero que nadie quiere
hablar del tema Entonces yo creo que si
todas esas cosas se ponen en línea
y y se tienen la otra parte
candidatos Que obviamente que el ex
presidente estuvo a favor de ellos los
cuales
estaban hablando acerca de fraude en las
elecciones que nunca se aprobó yo creo
que que pueda que exista una una
habilidad de de que ciertas ciertos
demócratas en lugares que son más
que pueden irse un lado al otro puede
que exista que puedan ganar el el poder
ahora lo que pasa normalmente es que en
las elecciones de medio tiempo
normalmente siempre hay un cambio de de
partido que controlada la la cámara
del representantes y yo creo que eso es
algo que están esperando en en estas
elecciones me dos minutos para finalizar
el programa quiero finalizar con con una
perspectiva que se está viendo desde
América Latina en cuanto a la situación
que se ha presentado en Estados Unidos
no solamente ahora con esta coyuntura
sino en los últimos meses desde las
elecciones presidenciales esas dudas
sobre la institucionalidad las dudas
sobre las instituciones federales en
Estados Unidos la insurrección de El 6
de enero ese ese fraude ese supuesto
fraude en las elecciones aquí lo estamos
viendo como una latinización de Estados
Unidos que supuestamente el ejemplo de
la Democracia para nuestra región es el
referente en el norte para América
Latina y vemos a Estados Unidos
completamente desordenado no solamente
en esta administración desde el final de
la Administración Trump cometiendo
muchísimos errores En cuanto a la
política exterior y unos movimientos que
uno no entiende qué es lo que busca
Estados Unidos como nación y como
ejemplo supuestamente para nuestra
región comienzo por María
Bueno yo corre gente yo no creo que se
cometieron errores en política exterior
con Donald Trump Donald Trump lo que
hizo fue firmar los acuerdos de paz en
el medio oriente controlar la
inmigración y el tráfico humano y
definitivamente detener a las
organizaciones internacionales que
acogen en su seno a los mayores
narcotraficantes y narcodificadores como
es el caso del Cuba Venezuela Nicaragua
yo sí creo que Estados Unidos con una
agenda tan progresista y con grupos como
Black slimeter o antifaz incendiando las
ciudades o como se me olvidó decir como
las amenazas de muerte a los jueces del
tribunal supremo Eso sí por defender el
derecho David por defender que los
estados nos corresponden definir el
futuro este país está en peligro la
institucionalidad de Estados Unidos
están entredichos Pero hace mucho tiempo
recordemos de nuevo Lo que pasó con
hillary Clinton temas porque nos
investigas y no creamos todo lo que nos
la cortó porque me queda pocos minutos
Daniel subo reflexión sobre esta
latinización si lo podemos llamar así de
Estados Unidos
lo que pasa aquí es es lo que le llamo
propaganda la propaganda Comenzó desde
el principio de la de la de cuando el
señor Trump para el presidente y siguió
así y eso fue lo que pasó durante todo
ese tiempo y terminó con lo que vimos el
6 de enero cuando todas las Cortes donde
se presentaron todos estos casos
alegando fraude no existió ni nada de
evidencia de fraude pero lo que pasa en
este momento es que estamos en un nivel
en que la democracia está en peligro y
la única manera que que debe de de de
ponerse en línea recta es tratar de
salir de esta clase de propaganda Daniel
muchísimas Muchísimas gracias se me
acaba el tiempo debo dar paso al
informativo María Daniel Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros así están
las cosas en Estados Unidos dejen sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales Siguen con nosotros
[Música]